[Music]
this week on q a our guest is andrew
coburn author of rumsfeld his rise fall
and catastrophic
[Music]
legacy coburn
february 20th
an ap story out of bluffton south
carolina
the first paragraph reads republican
presidential candidate john mccain said
monday the war in iraq has been
mismanaged for years and former defense
secretary donald rumsfeld will be
remembered as one of the worst in
history
why do you think he is saying that at
this point
well mccain um he has
as a supporter of the war overall i mean
he has to give an accounting of why
why nevertheless it's a
turned into a disaster so
he therefore is reaching out to donald
rumsfeld as the agent of the disaster
and if we can pin the blame on him then
the war itself gets sort of gets off the
hook i mean that seems to be what's
going through mccain's head
is that true that he is one of the worst
i'm not i'm not sure why he's one of the
worst
public officials one of the worst
secretaries of defense but what do you
think oh i think definitely mccain's on
the money there i mean
uh rumsfeld was definitely one of the
worst if not the worst secretary of
defense in history i mean um
his rival for that title is obviously
robert mcnamara
but in all sorts of area although
they ended up with disastrous wars on
their hands um which they'd helped
create
um
mcnamara in many ways was a much more
competent official than rumsfeld turned
out to be
you have a new book out
and you have a cover picture that you
they're using at scribner uh uh donald
rumsell where is this picture from do
you know
it's from just uh from one of his um one
of his briefings um it was a
shot a stray shot by uh by a
photographer that i think rather
excellently captures the man
why do you think it's excellent
because it shows i think a
hardness
um
you know he was always
normally when you saw rumsfeld in public
he was smiling
he was you know he had that's one thing
he was very good at was sort of
bantering with the press
um
and his
demeanor often
as best he could concealed but i think
was a very sort of chilly interior
and a
rather a very stony temperament when did
you start this book
i started this book i already started
thinking about it two years ago um i
started intense work on it
a year ago
and then come november 8th i was you
know proceeding along in a quite
equitable fashion until
the day after election day last year
when i got run by the publishers and
a gun was put to my head sort of through
the telephone and they said um you
basically have a month to finish it what
was your reaction when he had resigned
well in a way
a lot of people rang up to sympathize
they said oh he's gone but i felt a
certain relief um not just as a citizen
but also
because
i knew how it ended then i mean i was
wondering was this man going to go on
and on because he was he'd been
he'd been in play as i said in the book
ever since the general's
uh the retired general started
denouncing him in
april of last year of 2006
and
at that point it seemed only a matter of
time um
because it was open season on rumsfeld
and then during the election campaign
itself last fall
it became a sort of matter of rote for
every republican candidate to say
and donald rumsfeld has to go i mean
even joe lieberman
you know as earnest of partisan of the
war as could be found even he felt it
necessary to say that donald rumsfeld
had to go so it really was a matter of
time and
i felt it was good to get it over with
maybe he did too on page 80 um
you say in in spite of the enormous
shadows these men would together cast
across the united states in the world
this crucial moment has never been
revealed or discussed and that crucial
moment has to do with dick cheney and
the their friendship or
explain why you say this has never been
revealed and why did you reveal it
well it's an extraordinary interesting
moment i mean we have got used to though
we got used over six years of this
administration to
to the presence of these two dominant
figures in the bush administration uh
donald rumsfeld and dick cheney and they
were always described as friends since
the ford administration or even
since before that since the next
administration when
cheney had gone to work for rumsfeld
jenny was a young young fellow out of
wyoming
and
no one had ever known that they had
actually had a very deep breach for a
period and that was in 1986
when rumsfeld was getting ready to run
for president
which he did for the 1988 nomination and
presidential
and he'd gotten very used
during the white house years of the
mid-seventies to having dick cheney by
his side i mean everyone referred to
cheney as rumsfeld's flunky um
and so
rosfeld reached out to shady and said
okay i'm about to announce and i'm
embarking on this thing and i want you
by my side
and cheney said i'd do almost anything
for you but not this i've you know i've
moved on politically actually what was
happening was cheney was thinking of his
own
presidential race possibly if not for 88
for 92
and he was you know was forging a close
relationship with the bush campaign
so
um he turned rumsfeld down and rumford
was furious was absolutely furious he
said everything you are i've made you
you know he couldn't believe that his
you know his sidekick his faithful
faithful fellow had actually was
disobeying orders was jumping ship
and that's never been really discussed i
mean i know about it from people who
were very close to rumsfeld at that time
and he discussed it with them in fact uh
they were very aware of that phone phone
conversation and the only public sign
for anyone who was might have been
watching
was during while cheney was secretary of
defense under
bush senior
uh from 89 to 92 um
he had a big gathering of the formers
meaning former secretaries of defense
and they all sort of staggered in uh
back to mar-ups leicester and so forth
and the only one who wasn't there was
donald rumsfeld he stayed away
where'd you find this nugget
i found it from someone who was had been
very close to rumsfeld
both in his um public and commercial
career
and
because
romsfelt when he ran for president he
basically he brought over a bunch of
people from his corporate um undertaking
he'd been head of gd searle
the then pharmaceutical company doesn't
exist anymore and he brought over people
from searle
to run his campaign which as it turned
out was perhaps not such a good idea
because they might have been good at
running a pharmaceutical company but
people other people
political professionals um particularly
from the chicago area which is where all
this was happening said they were amazed
told me they were amazed at how little
in a way rumsfeld knew about electoral
politics which was one of the more
surprising things i discovered during
this book
there's a moment in the book where
you're in the pentagon
yeah watching a parade of sorts
it was extraordinary they started having
um it was a year or so into the war um
as walter reed
started to fill up with you know
horribly wounded people including
people who had lost limbs um they
started bringing them down
and wheeling them around bringing them
sort of a parade i mean
everyone was either in a wheel not not
everyone but
most people write in either in
wheelchairs or on gurneys in some cases
and wheeling them around
the a ring of the pentagon which is the
innermost ring
overlooks the courtyard in the center
and all the
workers in the pentagon i mean there's
the bureaucrats i mean not nothing wrong
with being a bureaucrat but these are
office workers um all come out and line
the corridor and all applaud so you can
hear from far down the corridor you can
hear
this applause growing but clapping um
as these put these unfortunate men and
women a wheel past
and i found it very you know it was a
moment it's one of the rare moments
where you actually see the war
in the pentagon
um and they do it about every month and
i was particularly struck when i was
looking at the
the notice someone gave me an email that
had gone round this is not for the
public or the press of course um
this had gone round from from a public
affairs official who has helped me
organize it and he said for this is the
first time we'll have all amputees i
think the pentagon loves milestones you
know first this first that this was
first all amputees
why were you there
i was i'd heard about it and i got a
friend who worked there in the pentagon
to to bring me in and to see this
bizarre
event i mean it was something very
strange i mean i guess it's good they'd
do it but you know then everyone
everyone went back to their offices and
got on with you know
running the machinery of the department
of defense it was like a sort of
i don't want to be
dismissive of it because it was i guess
it was a nice gesture and certainly the
families people the wounded men and
women had their families with them
or most of them did so i don't want to
be dismissive of it but i thought this
is almost a token gesture you know
here's this enormous machine grinding
away and
six or seven thousand miles away
wherever it in in iraq and afghanistan
you know there's this horrible blood and
death and suffering and people being
maimed and this is like once a month we
acknowledge that and then get back to
work
did you ask mr rumsfeld for an interview
i did and what did he tell you nothing i
had no response
why do you think he would talk to bob
woodward and not you
uh well he's had a long relationship
with woodward
and
if you read the interview with bob
woodward which is mr brownsville had
this very
fortunate and
uh habit which i i very much appreciate
as a journalist
putting every interview he did
unexpected i mean the full text
from the transcription up up on the
website um so um
obviously you can read i mean his
interviews mr woodward is a very good
interviewer and you can see that he had
cultivated a long relationship with mr
rossville going back to
i think the you know the ford
administration so um he was fortunate
enough to be granted the presence but
i'd since rumsfeld is
so much of what he said and done is on
the you know is there for us to find out
i wasn't too regretful
and what made scribner think that
this would sell
well um glad to see in your book
they were persuaded that
donald rumsfeld has been a dom a huge
figure in our lives i mean in this
administration which has
been a hugely
impactive administration i mean
it's affected the lives of more people
around the world than
other administrations for many you know
i would argue for you know for decades
and you know one of the dominant figures
in this administration has been donald
rumsfeld i mean he
i was talking a quote in the book a
white house official um
who
was working in the national security
area and i was asking this is back when
rumsfeld was still in the job and i said
what's um
you know is he really that powerful and
he said look he says he has control of
half of the discretionary budget of the
united states government
and plus that he has an effective veto
on u.s foreign policy so how effective
is that so this is like
i mean this man has been as powerful as
many presidents um so of course we
should have a book about him let me
start by reading on page one your
introduction and get you to tell some of
this
just after 9 37 a.m on the morning of
september the 11th 2001 officer aubry
davis of the pentagon police
was standing outside donald rumsell's
office on the third floor of the
pentagon's e-ring
inside rumsfeld though aware that the
world trade center towers in new york
had already been hit was proceeding with
his regularly scheduled cia briefing
how did you know
to go to aubry davis
um i asked at the pentagon i said who
was with rumsfeld um
on that morning um because you know it's
always been we had the initial version
of what had happened that he had you
know the crash had happened the plane
had hit the pentagon and he dashed out
to help with the wounded and i was just
very curious as to what
what had actually happened what had he
done how much time had he spent there so
i looked and looked to find someone
who'd been with him and was fortunate
enough to discover
officer davis you write quote there was
an incredibly loud boom says davis
raising his voice slightly on the last
word
15 or 20 seconds later just as his radio
crackled with a message the door opened
and rumsfeld walked out looking composed
and wearing the jacket he normally
discarded while in his office
sir said davis quoting what he had heard
on his radio we're getting a report that
an airplane has hit the mall
yes i mean it was uh i found it that was
so interesting that rumsfeld normally
inside his office i couldn't discover
what he was wearing inside his office
that morning but normally he would take
off his suit jacket
and put on a
sort of like a vest because he found a
chili in the office um
so
i think i don't know you wouldn't tell
me but i think he had time to change his
clothes put on his going outside jacket
come out and then he
see davis is there
and as i go on to say he
he didn't say a word he just marched off
towards the mall where it turned out the
plane hadn't hit it was further along
the pentagon but um
it's you know his extraordinary moment
he didn't you'd think he would have been
rushing off to find out since this was
now the third plane he knew two other
planes that hit in new york
um the third plane to hit a major
american target he might have gone along
to the command center to find out what
was happening but it it was a very
typical rumsfeld thing to do it was a
moment of micromanagement you know he's
the man in charge of the u.s defense
system
and he goes off to look at the fire
which i have a certain sneaking sympathy
with because that's what any of us would
want to do
but he had kind of a bigger job to do as
well did you consider that a metaphor
for the book for rumsfeld yes i thought
everything that happened that day was
kind of a was a metaphor for rumsfeld um
you know he micro he in a way he
abandons his wider responsibilities
to go look at you know to go look at the
fire um he's completely
what was very irresponsible was he
didn't appreciate that he was completely
out of communication i mean davis's
radio was crackling
with the voice saying where's the
secretary where's the secretary dr
cambone who was
very stephen campone who was a very
close aide to rumsfeld was i was asking
where's the secretary where's where's
secretary rumsfeld
and uh davis was trying to answer he's
here i got him i got him he's with me
we're at the mall or we're going down to
the we're outside
uh all you know the next uh 20 minutes
or so and he couldn't get through the
radio was too jammed up
so it was only a few minutes i mean it's
roughly 20 or just over 20 minutes he
was missing
but they were a very you know the united
states was under attack if you think
about it
during the cold war we were always told
that when the word comes that the
missiles are coming in that they might
be attacking us there's only like a few
the president or whoever
the national command authority would
have like four minutes or three minutes
or you know matter of seconds almost to
make crucial decisions
so here finally the country was under
attack and yet the secretary of defense
disappears for 20 minutes
so what do you think all that means
though as far as his life is concerned
well and the way he ran the pentagon
it was like he was just just the way he
ran the pentagon it's the way he ran
like when he was in charge of judy's
cell i mean um
one of his executives then said don
likes to dive down to the weeds you know
he likes to heal focus in on one micro
issue in this case it was you know
where a plane had just plowed into the
um
into a side of the pentagon and to the
exclusion of like what the wider picture
was um
then he uh
you know he's any
other things that happened the day that
they were also in pattern with him he uh
he immediately started
well not almost immediately he uh
he got then he came back to the uh to
the national command center finally in
which he finally entered at 10 30 that
morning
and he immediately starts to work on
something that was completely irrelevant
which was rules of engagements for the
uh for pilots interceptor pilots uh
although the last you know hijacked
plane had crashed um sometime before so
then he does that for quite a while
until one o'clock he says
then he um
[Music]
by two o'clock he's um he's already
disparaging the notion that uh when they
come in with intelligence that it might
have been osama bin laden
or it probably was in some bin laden he
dismisses that
he says oh no you know he because he i
think he was probably thinking
remembering that not long before on
september 4th he'd had a briefing that
it was quite likely that al al qaeda was
going to attack the united states so he
like i think like many other senior or
several other senior administration
officials was
recalling that they had been warned
about this and there were going to be
some hard questions asked
questions unfortunately weren't that
hard but it must have been a guilty
moment for them so
then
at uh as i show from the notes taken by
stephen campone early that afternoon
he's already saying
um
oh well let's uh you know we should
really go after saddam hussein
so you know it's it's what i'm why
that's a parable i think for the general
rumsfeld is that he's immediately sort
of shifting responsibility
um and he has a
one of his old associates said to me don
has an acute sense of incoming lethality
you know you can see where his own
position is threatened and this was
obviously a very threatening moment for
him i mean they disregarded warnings of
an impending attack and the attack had
happened so what to do now why did
nelson rockefeller and george herbert
walker bush dislike him so much
because they were victims
of his ambition
back in the mid 1970s during the ford
administration
rumsfeld i mean one thing we have to
understand about donald rumsfeld is how
extraordinarily ambitious
he's been
and he certainly was in the mid-1970s
when
he'd been i mean just a little bit of
background he'd been basically shoved
out of the nixon white house because
holdemon and erlickman didn't like him
didn't trust him
and he'd been sent off to be the
ambassador to nato
when nixon
the final days of nixon or the final
weeks of nixon he realizes that this is
his big opportunity and he's coming back
all the time he sort of denied this
later but he was flying back to
washington all the time and preparing
the way
for
a position in the what would be the ford
administration and he knew jerry ford
well from when they were both in
congress
so
his plan his long-term plan seems to be
in that point he gets you know he gets
appointed chief of staff of the white
house
and he wants to be president donald
rumsfeld has always thought that he is
by far the best qualified person in
these united states to be present
president of the united states or he did
that think that until recently anyway
he has a problem
uh
he well he decides that the way to do
this is to become ford's vice president
and then
run with him in 76 and then in 1980
perhaps run himself on the ticket to be
president
the problem is that ford
picks almost immediately nelson
rockefeller to be his vice president and
the second problem is as chief of staff
of the white house isn't really as
adequate jumping off you know isn't
adequate on your resume to then run for
president he needs to have had a big
cabinet level appointment
so he
what he did to rockefeller so far as i
could establish was to
give the impression produce the
impression in the ford political
campaign that rockefeller was a drag on
the ticket that rockefeller was too
liberal
and he did that so it was suggested to
me because he was had meant to have
overall supervision of um ford's
re-election effort
by letting the campaign sort of
run off the road a bit so people said oh
the campaign's not going too well it
must be because we've got that liberal
rockefeller on the ticket
and it worked
eventually it was decided that they had
to dump rockefeller in order to because
ronald reagan was coming along on the
right
they had to shift forward to the right
by getting rid of rockefeller so
bingo he's gotten rid of
now there's no fight the vice
presidential slot is open
okay the next thing is the cabinet level
position well
he tried first to get he thought
sexually the treasury would be good so
suddenly but there was a sector of the
treasury william simon so suddenly all
sorts of very disobliging articles began
to appear in major newspapers saying
that william simon was doing a terrible
job and jerry president ford was getting
fed up with secretary simon and
secretary simon was for the high jump
very soon and simon was going crazy
reading this he thinks my god the
president is putting this out i might as
well resign and then it was discovered a
friend of uh simon's discovered this was
going on
and discovered that ford didn't
um
uh want to get rid of simon and rang
rumsfeld and said and wrote a piece it
was a journalist wrote a piece charles
bartlett wrote an article saying um
that rumsfeld was having this intrigue
against was producing all these leaks
via chaney
then he rang rumsfeld and said this is
going i'm putting this on the wire in 10
minutes
and rounds felt there was he said there
was a pause and romsfeld said this will
stop now and he's bartlett insisted that
rumsfeld make a public expression of
support for simon so that initiative was
killed
okay so the next
let me stop just to ask you did you talk
to charlie bartlett about it i did yeah
he's still alive he's still alive he he
pops up so often in all these books as
someone who knew all these stories mine
of information yeah i know he gave me
chapter and verse i'd heard the story
already from someone else and he
confirmed every every point about it and
he described this conversation with
rumsfeld
and he faces rumsfeld with the fact that
he knows what rumsfeld is up to
in trying to get rid of simon and when
did he stop writing charlie bartlett
well i think he's still putting out his
newsletter isn't he i don't know i
haven't seen the news later but yeah he
is yeah
should we all be so productive so long
i mean bartlett you know he's been doing
this he's been producing this very
informative newsletter for the decades
so then ramsfeld the next thing that
happens is that the secretary of defense
james schlesinger
is this he's an economics professor and
he doesn't well ford doesn't like him
ford finds him arrogant
or didn't like things like when the
secretary of defense came in to see him
the president united states he wouldn't
even bother to do up his shirt but he's
you know he's the top button on his
shirt and he would lecture him
so ford didn't like schlesinger much
anyway
and there came a time in october
1975
when
under rumsfelds i mean
ford
this wasn't all rumsfeld but ford if
ford certainly went along with it i
thought it was a good idea they decided
to have a major reshuffle urged on by
rumsfeld by which schlesinger got fired
rumsfeld got the pentagon
and george but there were many other
moving chairs but george bush
who was already being talked about have
been george bush was talked about as a
possible vice president
he was then ambassador in beijing he is
brought back but made head of the cia
which was thought to be a political
graveyard i mean once you've been out of
the cia was sort of considered a
non-political job so that ruled you out
politically
and
bush thought correctly that rumsfeld had
orchestrated this
to put him bush a rival
in the in the cia
leaving the way clear for rumsfeld to be
nominated as vice president
why would then george walker bush choose
him to be defense secretary or did he
well it's not an interesting question um
it's no secret that there's a rivalry
that george walker bush has
problems with his father i mean
this has been you know written about and
quoted i mean bob woodward he said to
bob woodward you know i follow the
direction of a higher father not my
biological father or what he said
there's i've come across numerous you
know uh
statements from people who who know them
both who've seen you know stray remarks
you know like that um oh someone bush
was cycling with
once george walker bush sort of said um
they said
sorry was running was running a marathon
and someone said oh you know you're
pretty fit
and he said yeah better than my dad you
know it's like this he said he feels
this need to
to compete with his father
so
when you say you know did he pick
rumsfeld as his as his secretary of
defense yes he did i mean however much
he's under the influence of dick cheney
or whoever
had he
wanted to he could have refused to
accept a man who was a lifelong or for
decades had been on bitter terms with
his father
and that was you know that was
definitely known he had to know the
history that george
bush senior
you know one of
one of the few people he ever speaks of
uh spoken of with bitterness because
he's a very equitable fellow
one of the few people he speaks of
bitterly is donald rumsfeld because of
what happened as i told you in
in 1975
rumsfeld when he went to chicago
i heard recently uh
after in 1977 he would entertain dinner
parties with him and imitations of
george herbert walker bush which senior
he was rather good mimic rumsfeld
so the business between the two was well
known and yet bush jr picks him to be
secretary of defense
that to my mind tells us something quite
uh tells us quite a lot about the
relationship between bush jr
and bush senior
let me ask you about your own views on
the iraq war
well
clearly i mean retrospectively it's been
a huge disaster
and it's been a disaster because
it was all entered into so casually
um it was so i mean not just rumsfeld i
have to
take slight issue with don with uh
senator mccain here i mean it was clear
to me it seemed clear to me
from fairly early on i mean from the
even before it started that first of all
it was all based on a lie
um
because of a previous book i'd done on
saddam hussein
i knew there were either no weapons of
mass destruction whatsoever or
you know a few token sort of
decaying rusting warheads at most of
chemical weapons um
it was clear to me there was no nuclear
program in fact there was plenty of
evidence it wasn't very hard to find
that i mean there were iraqi nuclear
scientists out in the world who could
tell you that
so it was all based on a lie um
and that saddam was no threat to man or
beast outside his country
there's a story i tell in there about a
parade in 1998 a military parade in
baghdad where elite units were marching
past the reviewing stand being looked at
by saddam
and there was one elite unit who was
obviously their dress uniform
was white included white gloves
but if you look closely you could see
they were wearing white socks
now a regime who can't afford to get
gloves for its elite unit
quite certainly isn't building a nuclear
weapon i mean uh
it seemed ludicrous so the war was
clearly based on a lie
monstrous lie
and
also it seemed that you know that all
these the fact that they seem to be
i didn't quite understand at the time
what was really going on inside the
administration but it seemed that they
were nominating ahmed chalabi to be the
new leader of iraq i mean i knew a lot
about charlotte this seemed to be a
recipe for disaster too so
you could call me cold on the you know
sort of uh
bleak on the war from the very beginning
and the last time i saw you was 16 years
ago
in september of 91 you had your wife
leslie with you
your daughters were 12 and 7. if i
figure it right there 23 and 28. this is
true
and you did this book by yourself not
with your wife bring us up today on your
family
well um
my elder daughter is just about to
graduate from harvard law school um
my god i think it was
sorry if you put the ages of my children
back then it does take me back
and my younger daughter is a very
successful actress in hollywood um
where do you see her
i see her um i see her in movies i see
her um
i'm about to
she's making her own career so i don't
want to uh she doesn't want to carry the
baggage of um
well i'll see her um i'll see her
actually tomorrow night
in uh
an nbc document drama series the black
donald is which is uh premiering
tomorrow tomorrow night yeah by the time
this is on that will have already run so
uh sorry that's all right um and your
wife leslie
my wife leslie um
she's been producing for 60 minutes very
successfully she's um
she's she wrote her since we spoke she
wrote a brilliant memoir looking for
trouble um describing six wars six wars
in a revolution because she's much
braver than i am and she's uh
she's covered the uh
she goes to the sharp end and various
wars we we've visited iraq um
we went to iraq a number of times
together um
since this last war uh yeah actually the
last time we were in iraq together we
went to abu ghraib
unfound this is before the abu ghraib
scandal well what was going on there was
really revealed
and um indeed we found that they were or
she felt she was making 60 minutes and
she brought me along
and we found um
they were you know keeping prisoners off
the books there i mean it was a
precursor to what was eventually
exploded
has there ever been a book written about
the coburn family and i'll ask you again
i asked you 16 years ago why it's coburn
instead of cockburn
uh i think i can't remember what i said
16 years ago but the best i can do is
it's some scottish
uh it's a scottish family it's a
scottish name so um maybe it's you know
it's i mean there is a cockerel on the
family crest so
as some of you know some once upon a
time they may have pronounced it
cockburn but the coburns
you know for hundreds of years have
pronounced and pronounced the name that
way but has there ever been a book
written about the family
no about your father my father wrote
wrote his order wrote several volumes of
autobiography which are well worth
reading
your i mean if we go down the list
your father was born in china yes
your brother patrick was born in
scotland
um no he was born ireland you were born
in london in london and your brother
alec alexander was born in
in scotland in scotland so yeah
all over the place over there that's
right where do they all live now your
father's been dead since what 1881
uh that's right um
well my brother elder brother alexander
lives in california my younger brother
patrick
lives between
england and baghdad because he's been
covering iraq on an ongoing basis since
the war so it's uh
you can say patrick cobin care of the
alhamra hotel baghdad um and you live
here and i live here and there's laura
flanders the talk show host that's right
she's my niece um the daughter of my
late sister claudia
she's a little she lives in new york
um and indeed i have another niece uh
her sister stephanie who is the
uh
chief economics correspondent at the bbc
so go back to your dad i guess that
would is he would he be the one that
would be the representative of all this
starting out as a writer
yes i guess he was the first journalist
in the family um what was his name
claude coburn
um and he always wanted i mean as we all
sort of slipped into the journalistic
life uh myself and my brothers i mean he
said oh my god you know it's a life of
it's a hard life he didn't want us to be
journalists i mean he didn't discourage
us but
he said he didn't try and stop us that
he thought it was time some coburn did
something else but so far that has not
happened what did he do
he
he did a lot of things among other
things he invented the newsletter
um in 1933 or
32 33 as hitler was taking over
in germany and taking over in germany
and looked like fascism was on the rise
in europe
and he'd been he'd worked for the london
times he'd been a correspondent actually
here for the london times
and he was very conscious
that then much more than today the
papers you know were very in england
certainly were very opaque they wouldn't
tell you what was really going on what
people in the elite in the surrounding
circles knew was happening
and they wouldn't reveal to the outside
world you know to their readers you know
they'd only say what they thought the
readers should know
so he started a newsletter to convey
this
inside information what was it called
it's called the week
it was very it successful enormously
influential um because all
it started to get it was then began
being being quoted
in um
in newspapers here in this country in
europe and it became you know it
it lubricated the information machinery
um
and indeed hitler was always demanding
that the that uh that it'd be better the
british government ban it um mussolini
to
it got my father put on hitler's death
list for when if you know had he
conquered england and been able to lay
his hands on my father he would have
shot him immediately so it was a tribute
when did he write under the assumed name
of frank pitcairn
um
that was in the 30s too he had a whole
he had a huge number of assumed um
well he was more they proliferated
because he was he was very left-wing in
fact he was in the communist party for a
while so he um
he was blacklisted later on so he's i
mean
and he had the supreme i guess his
greatest sort of tribute was in the same
week
he was denounced in a communist court in
czechoslovakia as a british agent
and you know
had
stalin got his hands on him he would
have shot him because he'd left the
party
and the same time senator mccarthy here
called him one of the most dangerous
reds in the world so
no one could figure him out your brother
alexander was born in 1941
i haven't seen it much
lately is he still active in writing
yeah absolutely he has a very successful
um online one newsletter that's both in
print and online called counterpunch um
uh he's a column in the nation so he's
beavering away he lives in
rural bliss in the remote woods of
northern california and brother patrick
is how old
uh patrick is 57
and
as i say commutes between london and
baghdad
are any of you american citizens
no
both alexander and i are embarking on
that
on that procedure
why because well my family is american
you know
i feel i've lived here
as a
as a
a legal visitor
um
a legal resident for all these years
this time i actually uh
signed on
why do you think the family
uh is made up of all writers and public
people like that whether the movies or
television
what's the best working for a living i'm
not sure what's the thread and who
encouraged you to do that
well i'd say no one really encouraged me
to do it um i just thought it was more
interesting than
you know
telling stories about what's going on
finding out what's going on and
explaining to people what's going on was
much more interesting than any other
occupation on offer i mean
you find
there aren't that many ex-journalists
around people i mean people once you're
a journalist it's very hard to do
anything else everything else seems kind
of mundane or not so much mundane but
you know you're rooted in one
you know in one channel whereas as a
journalist you can you know the world
the world is your oyster how many books
have you written
uh
five and which one did the best
ah that's a good question in a way the
first one i did i guess which was um
i wrote it was called the threat in 1981
um probably in 1982 a bigger pod
uh inside the soviet military machine
and this was at a time when
the soviet military
were being spoken of by one and all as
this mighty instrument
soviet soldier 10 foot tall you know we
the united states could barely keep up
they were in danger of
overcoming us a point of view
assiduously promoted i might say by
donald rumsfeld but um
and i just i just started talking to
people who'd been in the russian
military because they had
a huge number of people had emigrated
actually in the 1970s and many of them
had come to live in this country um
they dawned on me one day when i
realized that every cab i was living in
new york every cab i took in new york
had a russian driver
so i started to say to them were you in
the army and of course the universal
draft there and they all had been in the
army i said what was it like oh it was
terrible you know what was the training
like oh we never trained you know no
live ammunition everyone drunk all the
time and
you know
you know i did more research than that
but it confirmed this initial picture
that the thing was basically a shambles
which was confirmed in spades once the
soviet union fell the book that you
wrote that we talked about 16 years ago
is dangerous liaison the inside story of
the u.s israeli covert relationship
anything changed
um
no i mean yes lots of things have
happened but there's still not a
wonderful thing yes
um
yes i mean the relationship if anything
has gotten
deeper
since since we wrote that book
we see you know this is this
administration um is probably the most
is the closest to israel to the israeli
government we we've ever had i think um
i mean it's not it's ever gotten that
distant except for a brief moment in the
first bush administration
but um you know as we see you know that
the two two countries have been working
very closely in the middle east in the
last in throughout this administration
and uh
to a degree that i must say far exceeds
anything that ever went before
back to the rumsfeld book you uh have a
chapter which is uh frustration and uh
to a degree that
i must say far exceeds anything that
ever went before
back to the rumsell book you uh have a
chapter which is uh
got the heading uh he's a ruthless
little bastard
yes so that was an immortal remark by
richard nixon um
again nixon did us the great favor of
taping all these conversations in the
oval office
and
he and his close you know his
uh his closest aides
erlichmann and uh holdemon
are discussing
rumsfeld
and they're talking about something they
want him to do
and you know they're agreeing that
rumsfeld is the guy to do it
and nixon says of rumsfeld he's a
ruthless little bastard i'll give you
that
it was actually one of the things that
made me think and i went and checked how
tall rumsfeld is when all that
all the time we ceased to see it in
these days of glory on the you know at
the pentagon and i always thought of him
as a big man but actually he's only just
over five foot eight
i was wondering why nixon called him
little
i wrote down a number of names and
they're familiar to the audience who
follows this and i'm just going to go
through the list and ask you to keep it
brief but give us a quick synopsis of
what you think of these folks
and you've already mentioned steve
cambone gambon um
kem bone c-a-m-b-o-n-e
who was he and what's the threat of the
relationship with donald rumsfeld
well cam bone he came out of he was sort
of a defense intellectual he'd worked at
los alamos as a political scientist um
he worked in think tanks he'd had a job
in the first bush administration
pentagon
rumsfeld found him they met when he was
he was hired as the staff director for a
commission uh
a sort of congressionally mandated
commission rumsfeld wren in the night
late 90s it was called the ballistic
missile missile it was on ballistic
missiles um
and cam bone worked to rumsfeld's great
satisfaction on that
runsville brought him into the pentagon
and successively promoted him
uh from being a sort of an assistant to
by the end uh rum
cambone
was in charge of the entire
defense intelligence
apparatus which was enormous consuming
billions of dollars and was ranked
number three in the pentagon
runsfeld changed the pecking order so
that the job that cam bone held liked or
not liked
loathed
respected not liked not liked by the
military not liked by other people in
ronsfell's inner circle for instance he
and paul wolfowitz deputy secretary were
at loggerheads a lot of the time they
were kind of rivals what's your take on
paul wolfowitz
very interesting character everyone sort
of if you look at all the what's been
written about rumsfeld in this
administration
welford kind of gets kind of a pass you
know he's a very nice fellow affable
academic always pleasant charming to
talk to and yet
he is as responsible
as rumsfeld for almost as responsible
for for many of the disasters that
happened he was
he was the one who really pushed the
iraq war
i mean on an ideological basis he'd been
pushing you know the overthrow of saddam
hussein since
certainly since the first bush
administration why
um
[Music]
he is you know he's i talk a lot about
the neoconservatives um the
neo-conservatives um
who
you know have a particular view of us
you know what's needed for us national
security
and
wolfowitz was one of those and they had
this vision of the middle east in which
among other things saddam hussein was
removed
um but wolfowitz you know he he pushed
he was an ardent proponent of
sending fewer troops to iraq he was an
ardent proponent of the war itself he
was involved in overseeing what was
going on in abu ghraib i mean he does
not deserve the free pass he's had
this is a quote from your book he liked
fight
because he was stupid that's in quotes
explain one former pentagon official who
worked closely with rumsel wolfowitz and
fight rumsfeld didn't want anyone else
going over to the white house and making
decisions so he would send fight knowing
that fife would argue endlessly in a
meeting and no one would be able to come
to a decision where did you get that
quote
i got that from someone who worked very
um
closely with rumsfeld in the in the in
the in the pentagon actually was and it
was kind of it was a sentiment that was
confirmed
by someone in the white house who was
actually would see was on the receiving
end of the enemy didn't tommy frank say
something like that in some at some
place well can i if i could i quote what
tommy frank said on sure on television
he called him the [ __ ] stupidest
guy on the face of this earth um
[Music]
so that was confirmed everyone
doug feith is you know generally known
as the as an extremely stupid person
um if he if he was so stupid why did he
get to where he was at the high level he
was in the pentagon well it was because
originally he was he was in charge of
policy
which at that time when he got the job
was the number three job in the pentagon
as i said as i explained rumsfeld
changed that later to make the
intelligence job the number three job so
originally and that was a very powerful
position almost eighteen hundred people
work in that department origi initially
uh russell wanted richard perle
um
a very you know potent figure in
washington for that job but paul was
making too much money in private
business and fife was very close to
pearl so
a lot of people regarded and it seems
correct to me that fight was there as
sort of pearl's representative and also
he was close to wolfowitz as a
neo-conservative in the pentagon in that
job it would do what it was told former
uh chairman of joint chiefs of staff
richard meyers is quoted as someone
called it saying about him he's
sycophant to end all sycophants yes
is that where did you find that well
people who uh that was a senior uh a
senior pentagon official unfortunately
didn't want to be named but he um
not a political appointee but a career
official who was in these meetings and
he said that you know that uh myers who
was personally selected by rumsfeld to
be chairman of the joint chiefs
was a psychopath um other people called
him in a rumsfeld game a very hard time
someone else
who was a white house official who
referred to him as an abused puppy i
mean very very nice fellow he's a very
nice fellow
but would never stand up to rumsfeld you
know felt would always try and please
rumsfeld and do rumsfeld's bidding
i don't know what the word is but is it
fair to
use this language in a book like this
about all these different people stupid
sycophant uh ruthless and all that when
some of these people won't step up and
be quoted
well i think that i think when in their
circle in the white house and in the
pentagon and else you know elsewhere in
the administration that is the general
impression that's what people say
i mean would it be fair to deny the
reader the knowledge this is how their
peers talked about them
and i think you know i think one should
give people this is this is the way you
know myers fight
wolfowitz
um
you know and all the other people i talk
about
are talked about let me just talk about
richard meyer i've never met the man but
but he was a four-star general in the
air force
he had to be
had to have something or he couldn't i
mean that's a pretty far road to go all
the way up there
i don't know whether he was academy or
not or
air force academy but anyway here is a
guy that
he had to get there was i mean he
couldn't have been a sycophant all the
way through the process
it would seem without he had to perform
at some point
well i mean unfortunately um what you
have in the military um today i mean not
in every case certainly but you know one
way to get ahead and what one way a lot
of officers senior officers do get ahead
is by you know their loyalties are
upwards
upward uh they um
you know you you ingratiate yourself
with your bosses um
and you become known among your peers as
a political general you call peter pace
a political general yeah well that's
again how he was regarded chairman yeah
the current chairman um
although it's interesting now i guess
he's coming he he seems to be prepared
to step over the traces occasionally but
he was known as perfect peter
because you know again
he you know these these officers are
very intensely ambitious i mean they do
you know they perform that assigned
tasks very adequately to the
satisfaction of their superiors
and there's a lot of people i mean i
long before i came to this rumsfeld
subject i mean friends of mine in the
military in the pentagon have lamented
the fact that the u.s officer call the
general officer corps is so thickly
populated with people like that who will
not say you know will not take a stand
on principle who um and will you know do
what their superiors ask which is one
reason we're in this mess why then do
people say we have the greatest military
in the world
or do we well
the greatest military for what
i don't know i mean
we have the great yes i know people but
i wonder when what do they mean by that
yes we have a you know we can blow up
the rest of the world probably more
efficiently than anyone else we have a
we have a military that can fight a
conventional war when the other side you
know fights with the same kinds of
weapons that we have
more efficiently than anyone else
probably um
but do we have a military that can deal
with uh
an insurgency like we have in iraq well
it's not clear we do and there's many
people
i mean i heard many complaints from
inside the military from inside the
people in iraq saying how
we're still we're trying to run this war
in a sort of bureaucratic top-down
fashion when the other side is doing it
differently is that the military's fault
or is that the civilian leadership
both both um you know the civilian
leadership is that we do have civilian
control of the military so the buck
stops
with you know the secretary of defense
if you pick this book up outside of this
country and read it you'd think that um
everybody in this country that runs
government hates each other
and that they're out to get each other
and that they're undermining each other
well
i say put it that way because that was
the impression after you know talking to
a lot of people in the uh in the
administration and then particularly in
the you know in the pentagon
administration the last few years that
that's that was the atmosphere i mean
that uh
rumsfeld and wilfowitz you know they
were they had a cold they don't know
they hated each other but they had a
cold relationship
did don rumsfeld choose paul wolfowitz
for the job
reluc not not really i mean reluctantly
i mean wolfowitz was cheney's candidate
um and waffle with uh wolfowitz had
other ties
um roseville originally didn't want
wilforwoods um
he uh uh wolfowitz
and he he couldn't make up his mind and
wolff was eventually had to say well
i've been offered the un job ambassador
to the un i'm taking that unless you
decide now so rosfeld took him
so
what's the steve herbert story i mean
he's a very interesting character
herbert's um
he and rumsfeld have known each other
since the nixon white house um he's a
very capable guy um
and he worked with rumsfeld in the
uh in the uh in his first incarnation of
secretary of defense
herbert's then went off um to work for
the sigrum liquor company for the
bronfman's um but also he came out as as
as gay
when um in the 19
i think in the 1980s i'm not entirely i
can't i'm not exactly sure when that
happened
but he you know especially rumsfeld
eminem actually moved to south miami
beach eventually it was a gay act very
active in the gay community there
for gay civil rights
and in fact gave money to the democrats
in 2000
because he said they had a better
position on gay rights
rumsfeld nonetheless brings him into the
pentagon particularly as to advise on
personnel matters
which
herbert's actually he has good expertise
and had done that for previous secretary
of sec secretaries of defense
and he was enormously influential in
rumsfeld's inner circle
despite being
an outspoken advocate of gay gay civil
rights which is i said says says
something for rumsfeld
but what's the story about the
you know the he ends up being secretary
general of the world jewish congress yes
what role did he play
and why did you say he wanted the number
two job
oh i say i talk about there's something
which people don't generally know when
they were um
the occupation of iraq uh you know when
they first in uh
april uh 2003
when we just moved into baghdad
and they're already discussing who's
going to be the viceroy i mean there's
this general jay garner was there as
meant to be the civilian overseer but
they already knew they were going to
pull him out and put in somewhere
somewhere more senior
and herbits you know as a personnel
expert he was you know drawing up
recommendations and he was recommending
wolfowitz
to be the viceroy
which that's we've known that for a
little while what people don't generally
know was that herbert's had another a
plan within the plan
was that he would go along as
wolfowitz's deputy
so you would have um
two uh well two as i say two passionate
supporters of israel who would be
running a major um arab country which
would have been interesting how much did
the
commitment to israel have to do with the
people around the president and their
interest in going into
iraq
i think a lot
to be honest why because saddam hussein
i mean it's very now we're hearing
stories of the israelis cancelled
against
attacking iraq i don't believe that i
mean i know from the time that these
israel was very much in favor of this
operation saddam hussein
was a major was seen as you know
although
by 2003 the regime was
tattered and you know bankrupt and
everything it still it was a formidable
had been a formidable
state saddam hussein was sending
money to the families of suicide bombers
on the west bank
ahmad shalaby
was promising the israel supporters that
you know once we've conquered iraq and
i'm in charge i will open relations with
israel we'll have a direct pipeline from
from uh
from iraq to israel all sorts of
wonderful things will flow
so i think it was an enormous attraction
people who had the cause of israel close
to their hearts thought this is going to
be great for israel once we've um
once we've uh taken over iraq just a
couple of uh moments left
you say this is out of context with
everything but you say you had the only
copy in washington of the revolt in
massabatana in mesopotamia from 1920 why
is that relevant
because this was this is an account by
the british general who um
who was in command of military commander
under the british occupation of iraq in
1920 when there was this massive revolt
when the uh both shia and sunni
um revolted against the against the
british administration and he put it
down
so i thought it was interesting that no
one else seemed to think this was an
important precedent and uh i lent it
with xerox and i think passed around
though not perhaps to
put to the best use one of the things
you were pointing out is if you look at
the uh
spine of this book you see
one of the eyes of uh don rumsfeld you
think that was done on purpose yes i've
i'm confident enough of the
designer's skill to think to know that
that was deliberately put that way why
would they do this because when you have
it on your bookshelf
i hope this won't be deterrent to people
buying it you'll have the bdi of donald
rumsfeld looking down at you
so after you went through this process
of writing this book what was the
biggest change in attitude you had about
donald rumsfeld
that he was much less competent than i
thought i thought that he was the
general um general impression was and he
was always spoken of as this you know
this this competent manager the guy who
could really you know make the trains
run on time and you know after seeing
what happened
in the pentagon and the way what went on
inside the pentagon while he was in
charge and how
you know so many things were let drift
how
how much chaos there was in the
managerial process that was a surprise
to me next book
not uh not about a secretary of defense
i think i'll i think i'll find um
i don't know who knows perhaps robert
gates
andrew coburn our guest the title of the
book is called rumsfeld thank you very
much for joining us thank you
[Music]
for a copy on dvd or vhs tape call
1-877-662-7726
for free transcripts or to give us your
comments about this program visit us at
q a dot org
q a programs are also available as
c-span podcasts
[Music]
you